The Master of the Mystic Arts may be coming
face to face with an old ally - and it won't
be a friendly reunion.
Inside sources are reporting that Baron Mordo,
who became thoroughly disillusioned with the
Ancient One at the end of ​Doctor Strange​,
will be the main antagonist of Doctor Strange
2.
Although the casting has yet to be confirmed,
this lines up well with the information we
do have.
Doctor Strange 2 was one of the forthcoming
Marvel flicks reported to be on the way by
the mysterious Twitter user "Roger Wardell"
in a massive leak earlier this month.
While we tend to take such things with a grain
of salt, the twitter user has leaked highly
accurate information in the past.
According to sources close to We Got This
Covered, the second solo outing for the good
doctor is in, quote, "deep development," with
the first film's director Scott Derrickson
and screenwriter C. Robert Cargill already
hard at work.
According to these sources, when we next see
Mordo, played by Chiwetel Ejiofor, he'll be
in "full-on villain" mode, intent on ridding
the world of magic.
While the details of Ejiofor's contract aren't
known, it's all but certain that he'll be
reprising his role given his impressive performance
in the first movie.
Ejiofor is a brilliant actor, and in Doctor
Strange, he invested Mordo with a strong set
of ideals and a conflicted nature that shone
through despite the character's relatively
limited screen time.
As we've seen, the MCU's greatest villains
aren't the ones who simply want to cause chaos
and/or rule the universe.
It's characters like Thanos, who enacted a
plan to wipe out half of all life in the universe
for supposedly benevolent reasons, and Loki,
who seems to constantly struggle against his
own worst impulses, who strike the biggest
chord among Marvel fans.
Mordo began Doctor Strange as a firm disciple
of the Ancient One and her ways, but was shaken
by the fact that she had harnessed power from
the Dark Dimension while forbidding her students
to do the same.
His assertion during the film's post-credits
scene speaks to a new worldview:
"Because I see at long last what is wrong
with this world"
"Too many sorcerors."
His new belief systems seem to be wrapped
up around the belief that to use magic at
all, even in defense of our entire universe,
is to invite catastrophe upon that universe.
At any rate, assuming the report is accurate,
Mordo is likely to be one of many villains
in play for Doctor Strange 2.
A previous leak from "Roger Wardell" has suggested
that the sequel will also take place in the
1980s and see the introduction of some new
characters.
Wardell wrote,
"Doctor Strange 2: 1980's Boogaloo.
Tilda Swinton is in talks to return as the
Ancient One.
Jericho Drumm and Clea will make their MCU
debuts, Clea will likely be portrayed by an
Asian actress.
Most importantly the gloves will be back!"
We should point out once again that none of
this has been confirmed, but we expect to
get a lot more information on the MCU's Phase
4 within the next few weeks.
In July, Marvel will present at San Diego
Comic Con's Hall H, where the studio has made
a ton of significant announcements in the
past.
However, even Hall H may simply be a warm-up
for a second presentation to follow at Disney's
D23 expo in August.
It's quite likely that Marvel's entire Phase
4 slate will be revealed at that time, and
we can finally confirm or debunk the seemingly
never-ending torrent of rumors which have
been leaking all year.
We'll be on the lookout for any more leaks,
and we'll keep you up to date.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about the MCU
are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.